الحرب في اوكرانيا اقتربت من اكمال عامها
الاول القتال يستمر في الارض كما في
السماء موسكو دخلت باستراتيجيه اساسها دحر
الجيش الاوكراني في وقت قياسي باستخدام
مختلف الاسلحه
لكن لا احد انتصر في المعركه
بوتين اعتمد على وابل من الصواريخ
الباليستيه مع الاحتفاظ بطائراته في بنك
الاحتياط طائرات باهضه التكلفه كسوخوي 35
في مرحله اخرى اعتمدت روسيا على المسيرات
الايرانيه الرخيصه الثمن لضرب البنيه
التحتيه الاوكرانيه في المقابل ردت
اوكرانيا جوا من خلال دمج انظمه الدفاع
الجوي الغربي في جيشها ما ادى الى تحسين
ادائه كصواريخ باتريوت وناس ثلاث مئه وعلى
الرغم من ذلك يؤكد خبراء ان معركه السماء
ما تزال متوازنه الى حد كبير في الفتره
الحاليه بالغالب ولا مغلوب
لكن مخاوف تسود من ان الكريم قد يحاول
اغراق الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه
بالقاذفات والطائرات المقاتله هو المروحيه
الهجوميه وكذلك بالصواريخ في محاوله
لايمالت كفه الحرب لصالح موسكو بلال
البشتين العربيه